I saw where Darius Rucker popular
country music star is going to be
singing the anthem with the Buffalo
Bills in New York Jets got a new single
out if I told you and Darius back on the
program you got any preparations when
you do the anthem you do anything
different um the only thing I really do
is I make sure I started very low yes
seem like Carlos most guys are too high
and that is always a bad thing so no I'm
always going oh say I'm doing my dad
Patrick voices for go out there every
time are you thinking of will you be
thinking of me thursday night in Buffalo
as you start when you go oh I will now
is there any food or drink for a singer
to avoid before the anthem Oh for me
dairy anything was looking I can't have
until after I think that could be a
theft what would happen oh my would gum
up my vocal cords like I probably suck
do you have a life sucka do you have a
cheat sheet like no I know the words I'm
jinxing myself no I know I as soon as i
said it a little while ago Seaton's like
oh you're gonna jinx darius there but
that you do know the word you've done
this many times where's your favorite
place you've done the anthem oh my
favorite place I've done the answer is
probably Levi Stadium the first time I
know I would have to say my favorite
place that done the anthem was up when I
did it at the at the Final Four and
Jerry world and it was my favorite place
because the first time I was ever scared
to death doing it was losing Jerry world
but why were you afraid there because I
walked it like 10 when we did rehearsal
it was just me and the choir I was doing
it with and it was no big deal don't I
walked out I looked around that place
man and it hit me that they were looking
ninety-five thousand people there then
it hit me there's probably a hundred
people really scared going up there
what's the part of the anthem where you
know you've either done it really well
or yeah
all the land of when you the land of the
free yeah when you get to land of the
free you know either was a good one or
look at that yes absolutely have you
ever gotten to a maybe a pitch where you
couldn't bring yourself back down safely
no I've been pretty cool with that the
funny thing goes when I did it at us I
did it at UH indy 500 this year they I'm
doing it now the guy's telling me to
stretch because we're waiting for the
planes no one's I never said and he said
I'm like how you stressed enough man so
pull my best luther vandross you know
the land it was funny it's kind of hard
you can't add another you know chorus or
something there absolutely i mean i'm
looking at he's going stretches i'm like
me we're talking to darius rucker he's
going to be singing the anthem in
buffalo on thursday night the bills in
the jets what do you make of all the
protest demonstrations with the anthem
ah you know that's that's one of the
reasons I want to Seattle because I
respect everything everybody's doing and
I understand the reason they're doing it
you know I would never tell anybody I
respected I think you know I see all the
points and you know most of the guys are
right but for me then you know this is
well the National of them and my respect
their right just to kneel down but I
also felt they respect my right to get
up and sing the anthem for my country
and I know we've had many discussions
about the Confederate flag and you've
been very vocal about that of you know
getting that taken down from the the
state house in South Carolina yeah you
know that everybody's got the protests
and the things they want to do in this
appeal Kaepernick has really started
something and then the best the best
thing about what he's done to start a
conversation and that that's how things
going to changing your debtors when we
talk about it and and so for me you know
I'm gonna get Bruce offenses dent
retired his jersey and called me up and
asked me to come in the party and said
amen we certainly happen for me not like
Bruce we've been friends a long time of
course example that's awesome now we saw
you in concert I saw you in concert
recently
uh you forgot the words to a song and it
wasn't like a new song no it was a
classic yes this was a Hootie in a
Blowfish song and the funny thing is the
only time it seems that happens when you
read cuz I'm cuz I every time you I kind
of looking for you for the words and you
I don't know and then and then your band
mates were saying go up there and help
him I'm thinking I there's fourteen
thousand people there I'm not going to
go up there and help you with I only
want to be with you I do need your
health so funny I sing a wrong verse and
it just I couldn't come it didn't come
back to me I couldn't come by and
actually the funny thing is the next
night I was like she was the word I was
so and and how many times have you you
sang that song oh goodness close
observer yeah Paulina dandy I team
seating has located some exclusive audio
Darius Rucker okay here we go
I don't know the words that Lord that's
the opening of the song you and me is
that funny that's what yeah I don't know
the word absolutely man so and it's only
when you're there that you see me I
think every time I've done it you were
there yeah but you don't get banged up
before the the show like you did with
the Blowfish like you're now an
important country star so I left you
alone again we did you know we didn't
get we got think we might have one girl
for the show stop the wars just eluded
me did you uh you cry when the Dolphins
wants to see em yes man that was a tough
one to take that was a tough man we had
that gaming and I gotta hand it to tani
11 saying I'm honest I want to see him
go down to arrest him we need to score a
touchdown and he did that and you know
then Russell Russell Wilson just comes
down and have a brilliant driving to
beat us that was a tough loss that would
have been a big one yeah would have been
that have been really a now you got the
Patriots coming up yeah Garoppolo we got
go rob you know we got to deal with that
guy we got to be labelled check again
what it might retire he's retire do you
think you would still the Patriots would
still win even if Bella jaggery tired
and still beat the door no way no way no
way Bell sex a genius man he's he's one
of them I think it might be one of the
three greatest coaches a long time I
mean you know you can take your guys and
beat beat his guys or take his guys beat
you what is that but uh you know now I
think we'd you know cuz Brady's gonna be
gone too and you having Garoppolo can
play proved that last week but you know
I want both of those guys retired Brady
in and and Bella check have you ever
invited Bella check to play drums and
one of your shows no I don't think he's
a fellow he's uh he's not a fan oh now
he didn't fight with Bon Jovi so I tell
you the guy who blew my mind is uh we're
in Dallas and Rick Carlisle is a friend
of mine and he calls me up and
hey man you can i chat with you guys
like yeah what do you plays like I
played ya knows like okay what he won't
play so I'll play let her cry okay you
know and so we've had that happen and
you know usually person gets up there
and they're they're adequate because
nothing great I'm telling you we out
there and Rick got up and got to the
solo part and we were just looking at
you like oh my goodness he's
unbelievable he's a great player he used
to play when he was with the Celtics
they'd go on the road they'd be he go to
the hotel bar where there would be a
piano and Carlisle would just be playing
so he'd sit down and just started
playing in the the hotel lobby of these
bars so I'm not surprised at all yeah he
should let you play point guard for like
a quarter I think so too man i think i
could help to master the playoffs i mean
you know i'm 50 but I could play yeah
yeah because she can't hear good seems
way when I was fully talking about 4 30
yeah exactly or twenty four twenty i
completed I got I did make it to the
last kind of a high school basketball so
that's kind of something see you're
almost like like Jordan got caught so
you were almost Michael Jordan almost
exact that was one cut away from this
when you're singing Thursday night I
think if you could give just a little
signal to this audience where we can all
sort of be there with you in Buffalo
singing that would be nice so what would
the gesture be thursday night right
before you get ready to go oh I don't
know um I will touch my cheek i'll press
my cheek right before i start saying
that suggested to you and you and your
whole ok and all the father Dan Patrick
show fans all right well good luck we're
all counting on you well thank you i'll
be out there man okay thanks bud talk to
you soon all good talk alright Darius
Rucker the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience